[Music]
hello and welcome to Playstation grenade
it's time to jump back into myth-busting
mode and find answers to the fortnight
questions you have they can be serious
they can be absolutely implausible and
completely absurd simply comment below
with your myth and upvotes
your favorites so here we go Chapter two
season two of myth chasers if you enjoy
this please think about using Cola
tomorrow in the shop and now let's stop
messing around bring on the myths to
[Music]
start we have a myth that needs
answering does a mini-boss fly at steamy
stags I'm sure you agree this is of
imperative importance we try to decide
which of the bosses we were going to
take to steamy stacks and then realized
it's actually impossible to get most of
them there because they don't stay alive
long enough when knocked which means we
can only use the yacht and therefore
this buff cat is our victim so before I
play this what do you think happens when
we get him to steamy stacks will he
float away or drop like a stone in that
Kevin juice let's check
[Music]
did you guess right he floats in the
updraft and waits for his demise we also
tested this with grunts and henchmen and
yes the same thing happens pretty damn
epic to me I don't think this will
change how we blow fortnight but it's
important all the same well that's not
the end of this myth we also discovered
something else
did you know it's actually possible to
interrogate someone whilst they are
floating in mid-air again completely
pointless information but dumb science
is what we all need right now our next
myths are all about the new Metal Gear
Solid cowboy box item there's tons of
these to get through so let's crack on
first boxes stop fall damage there's not
a chance that this is right is there
well let's try it all the same here we
go
[Music]
definitely not rip the dream next you
can use a launch pad and keep your box
this can't be right either can it well
here we go
and holy shizzle Batman it's true we can
use a launch pad with a cardboard box
around us our umbrella smashes a hole in
the top and we carry on regardless
another box myth boxes can go across zip
lines hmm this one sounds impossible but
let's try it and as expected it doesn't
work sadly but then we found if you
stand in the exact right place it is
indeed possible check this out who'da
thunk it we can use zip lines whilst
inside a box what up world we live in
let's have another box myth boxes can be
weaponized with c4 oh my gosh this
sounds epic
it reminds me of the old shopping cart
c4 shenanigans
so let's try it at first it's looking
pretty good it's absolutely broken but
the c4 sticks to that box of Neri anyway
and it follows any movement from that
character but here's the real moment of
truth can we explode this and knock our
opposition
[Music]
hell yeah hell yes we can the c-4 box
strat is officially here expect to see
every single daily youtuber doing
something with this from now on I think
this video is worth alike just for that
and to finish the car bhajan Hannigan's
let's go back to basics it's possible to
rock it right in a box yeah yeah I
couldn't resist no messing about let's
make them fly and of course it works
absolutely beautifully I could honestly
watch that all day it really could
as rocket riding is already on the menu
let's take this up a notch what about
this myth it's possible to rocket right
a henchman now this is a good myth off
we trekked in search of a rocket
launcher before the storm and other
players took us out when all was failing
we found it and decided to go to house
watch I just wanted to use that title
one last time rest in peace house watch
here's a moment of truth alright the
first attempt was terrible here's
attempt number 2 holy shizzle Batman
that is simply beautiful the bot was
even kind enough to stay completely
still once he landed on the rocket what
a guy now let's throw that myth your way
can you rocket ride a henchman that is
still stirred up I'm gonna try before
the next episode but if you manage it
please hit me up on my Twitter DMS I'm
Adam grenade and remember to share your
video on YouTube so I could get it in
the next episode good luck is it
possible to rocket Rider henchmen that
is still on their feet let's go back to
the boxes for a few more myths first we
wanted to check that even though traps
aren't in the game they may be coming
back so we tested this box's block trap
damage on this replay file for some
reason it says start bus I have no idea
why he's here so let's cover it up
back to the mints testing trap damage
was simple enough I invited a few people
from the discord and they jumped into
game and wandered around the ship in
boxes and this happened but oh well I
guess this myth is busted straight away
to double-check though I decided to use
dart traps and found something
mind-blowing the boxes are thick enough
to repel the darts and poison damage
interesting isn't it as a little extra
detail it's also apparent that if the
player has their head out of the box or
their feet are showing underneath and
they are hit too by the darts they will
take damage bloody brilliant
myth-busting so chapter 2 has introduced
a way to throw consumable items between
teammates what a wholesome activity so
we set ourselves a task can consumables
eliminate enemies I know it's a tall ask
we started by attempting to push one
another from ledges hoping that a tiny
bit of velocity was enough to move the
player off the edge it wasn't when
standing or kneeling it was completely
impossible but then we noticed that if
the throwable hit the person in the foot
when they weren't in touch with the
ground it pushed them forward so that's
our starting point the only thing we can
do now is build a sky base to attempt to
push each other off
we didn't take long at all this myth is
proven yes a bandage can kill a player
we won't finish there we wanted to try
something even more epic can a throwable
healing item prevent ball damage so the
exact same thing need to get to the
ground stood on top of a shield or a
bandage is it possible from the same sky
base in the same match moments later we
did this can you believe your eyes a
simple shield pot took a player to the
ground without any fall damage at all
it's so unfathomable the game's replay
file is having a fit
attempting to comprehend the numbers
Mason let's hope this doesn't count as
cheating okay I'm scared to try this
again but I am totally impressed by it
so there we have it another batch of
myths which was your favorite the flying
cap maybe please let me know if you'd
like more in this series I don't want to
overdo it
so let me know when you want another
episode oh and if you have a myth please
throw it my way in the comments below
and look around an upvote your favorites
down there too that would really help to
end let's get the leg end on screen
thank you so much for using cold atom
arrow this season I really appreciate
you if your name isn't here I probably
haven't got to your DM yet on Twitter
but I will do because for family aren't
we right I'll get my annoying voice out
of your ear holes
I am Adam from Playstation grenade it's
been an absolute pleasure I'll see you
next time
[Music]
by the way if you saw the super secret
super thick penny in this write down the
time code let's see if you're right
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Music]